no if I don't notice now feel like a
mind even I'm spinning a web yeah
I have no deniability I have no
deniability
[Music]
all right guys same as always same as
always we babble on our mothers every
episode yeah man subscribe to us on
YouTube
[ __ ] indeed sports cars follow us on
Instagram follow us on Twitter follow us
on Facebook you can also find us on
patreon if you download the app patreon
search shit's and gigs you can also help
us even further and be a part a bigger
part of the of the of the gang and buy
so much so it's all over it's all over
the place if you go on link tree on any
of our social media platforms you'll see
it there and even on a personal as well
select much find an array of great stuff
man so if you guys are feeling it make
sure you take a picture tag us and yes I
think we can shout you out as well so
yeah man also on the merch front we're
gonna start doing we'll start pushing it
a little bit more based just like an
idea floating around we're thinking
about started doing fan requests not
well no not fan submissions hmm so once
every once every couple of months we're
gonna open up a slot for fans of the
show to submit some designs that they've
put together mmm if you happen to be a
graphic designer great send us the
proper design and if it wins the wall
we'll slap it straight on obviously if
you're just someone of interest and
you've got no [ __ ] artistic talent
but this is your idea and you sketch
something together and say well this is
what I'm thinking about
then we'll [ __ ] pay if we think is
great then we'll [ __ ] pay for the
person to design it for us so yeah man
if you're into that let us know and
we'll we'll start show you now that's
that's got a house that happening soon
so yeah man I thought I'd be a cool cool
- I've got I've got a scenario for you
hit me so in this scenario you were
saying with that you've got you've got
kids I've got a daughter that's about 17
for example okay so you're you're older
now you know
but you still look good you still you
still feel and look as if you're in your
prime okay and you're obviously like
your 40-yard your push your 45 yeah yeah
you know me something around there yeah
yeah you're on a date today let's say
you live in LA for example okay because
everyone there's internet fitness which
you are into as well you're into their
health they're into the physique and
whatnot so you you pretend this local
gym where obviously everyone is buff cuz
everyone works out everyone trains there
and you start seeing a girl there that
starts clocking you as well she knows
you're older and you know she's young
but you know she's not young enough or
you think she's not young enough to be
that young she looks good she always
looks good but you don't you never
entertain anything because one you know
you know for you to even think that is
something wrong there's something wrong
yeah you know I mean bother ya you just
admire it and then just keep going with
your day yeah but you keep seeing a week
in week out week in week out and then
coincidentally you bump into her let's
say because you're trying to use a
machine she's using or vice versa she's
trying to use machine you use it so you
have to talk now
mmm-hmm so you start talking start
talking or whatever they've just it you
then the more and more you train the
more and more you realize oh [ __ ] we
actually taught now we're pretty cool
hmm and then this slowly starts to get
to flame
okay flying and just just enough to make
the gym session you make you want to go
to the gym even more you know you know
him and there's a chance about bumping
mm-hmm yes but you're at home one day
you're chillin yes
minding your own business minding your
own business your daughter comes home
from shopping one day she brings a
friend it's gym but her friend is the
girl your daughter's 17 she's 17 years
old as well I said how high this is blah
or from someone someone so and you see
her and you know who it is she sees you
and she knows who you are
prior to that you've never discussed
that you've got a kid right so you've
never discussed that you're a single
father because there's no need to have
that kind of discussion because you know
it's never going to go in that direction
anyway it's just so when you say
flirting hmm is it say is it is it
strong enough
now I should be worried when she walk
through the door
or is it something that if this girl
turns out to be a [ __ ] mm I'm not even
fast about what she thinks she knows
I've done you know I mean mmm I'm not
fun I'm not first about what she thinks
she's gonna accuse me of it's enough to
make you worry purely because you know
you've been speaking to her in a manner
that we both know not necessarily it's
inappropriate by it's more of a case of
you only wanted me and her to know about
this you don't want anyone to know yeah
don't even tell her boy you won't tell
me okay do you know I mean okay yeah
yeah so the fact that she's come home
now with your daughter what do you do
like what do you wait for her to say
something or do you just both leave it
you both pretend
ah Bravo
that's an interesting scenario that's
very interesting what would I do
[ __ ] because my initial reaction would
just want to be like aa gym thing mmm
gym ting mmm my initial reaction would
want to make it so playful and I'll be
like to my daughter like rah this is the
one that always tries to move to me at
the gym I make everyone more
uncomfortable than me
that's what my initial - would want to
be yeah oh you wouldn't think that was
first me at the gym she's so embarrassed
yeah I thought I could offer you is he
deflected or you know the stresses off
me yeah all the stresses off me now so
that's what I would want hmm
but it depends how the realisation of
her being 17 hits me in that moment
yeah to think that like how concerned am
I now that I've done something wrong
because then I'll stop I'll stop Kane
stuff round in my head like kind of like
kind of like when you've been in
relationships before
and then like your talk you're talking
to a female hmm and then like your
girlfriend's like oh you're like what's
happening a female whatever and she's
completely plutonic friend but you've
never spoken about her to your
girlfriend and then she's like oh who's
that
mmm for some reason you you're shaky
yeah shaky and for some reason you like
have I [ __ ] this girl before you know
you have yeah you know you've never did
anything before but you've got this this
this is this guilt on you yeah that you
like I must have done something because
why do I feel like this because it's
because you've not told your missus
about all you in the sketch in case I'm
not told your daughter rabbi but yeah
it's like yeah feels like it feels dirty
build a Jesus good day Jesus Christ
brought a ditch we can't answer it I
don't know I don't know cuz one side of
me it says the first thing where I'm
just like ah Jim ting mm how'd you find
out where I live if I had to be like dad
that musubi in the gym all the time
fare to be so embarrassed that
everything's calm now that can just go
back to playing dice that will be my
ideal scenario that's never gonna happen
but yeah I know when I walk in I cross
she's 17 I would immediately in my head
think I [ __ ] on and go in jail hmm
even though I know I haven't the
reaction I have that's all I'll be
thinking like I have [ __ ] up I'm going
prison 100% if I open any mouth I'm go
[ __ ] prison but it's I don't know if
I'd have it in me to lie to my daughter
but I don't know that she's I don't know
mmm [ __ ] [ __ ] bro I don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's hard in it I don't even
know why I came to why that came to mind
I think I would end up lying I'm being
all hi I'm just not talking to her yeah
hi and then afraid she played the same
prey place plays prey she plays the role
yeah and then if my daughter confronts
me abaya at least I have enough of back
in to be like oh yeah I knew it was her
but obviously I'm I didn't know I said
hi
go on my business I mean like I don't
know they want me to talk to her I
didn't know I didn't want to put him on
the spot or whatever I didn't want to
make you feel awkward I have so many
excuses yeah so many excuses but say
yeah I don't I would not initiate any
[ __ ] conversation I would end up
lying and playing like I don't know her
but only to the point where I have
deniability hmm if I get confronted
later I have enough deniability to be
like oh yeah I know she is here on the
gym but I didn't know if I don't know
cuz now I feel like I'm lying even
though I'm spinning a web yeah I have no
deniability
I have no deniability [ __ ] I have to be
something like oh it was her but I
didn't know I didn't want to be like oh
you're the one for the gym for her to go
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
maybe I have that angle I don't [ __ ]
know bruv Jesus [ __ ] you know what's
funny
mmm he knows funny putting myself out
there I used to be such a good liar when
we were younger
mm-hmm I used to be a horrible liar hmm
but I was so good so good it I was quick
with the lies quick with the I couldn't
believe it I was I was not a good person
especially he trumped me in it I
couldn't believe it
oh yeah there was a time I did there's
the time I had to throw you under the
bus to get myself out of danger at the
firm did you actually had to go for
context I'm not gonna say I'm not gonna
go into details but there was just a
time where I had [ __ ] up I was in a
relationship with someone I had done
something and I threw food under the bus
so badly that he had to take stick from
my girlfriend at the time forevermore
forevermore
I'm so sorry bro there was a time I saw
her in public because I knew what she
need ya know at first because when when
you were told me you threw me under the
bus I was shell-shocked I know you were
but because I had to understand why you
did that and think in your shoes for
example I'd be like
cool it's never gonna affect me
regardless cuz I don't see her anyway
yes fam today I saw her in public Alva
Toby I'll never forget it loser at
carnival right no wireless wireless
James are the odds
I would never I've never hidden so quick
in my life because I wasn't ready for
what she may have done or said to me
because I know what she believes is the
truth is a lie yeah yeah there's nothing
I can say cuz I'm not gonna try to
convince her it's a lie
oh because I have to back you now oh
yeah yeah yeah nothing I can say to
justify why I said what she thinks I
said because it's not true bro I hid
with such precision bro I've never been
so petrified I was riddled with guilt
I was riddled with guilt about doing
that I would never do it again but at
that time I'd I don't know what came
over me but to be put on that cuz the
thing I did I can't explain it without
saying what it is yeah I did
his was meant in pure Jess and was it
was more offensive to the other person
then it was to my girlfriend at the time
yeah yeah yeah but there was just no
there was no plausible justification for
why you can do that and it wasn't it
wasn't an action that I'd done so it
wasn't me [ __ ] anyone it wasn't me
doing anything it was basically a name I
had cooked it basically it was a name
I'd called another girl that was so
disrespectful so disrespectful so that
when my government the time found out
that I'd called another girl that that
she was like how can you possibly in a
million years think that's okay how can
I'm in a million years how can you think
that's okay on my immediate cowardly
reaction was to say who had did it
IFS food ads idea and it just happened
to be it just stuck
who had said it and it just stuck that
was my you and my scapegoat get that was
a girl Jeffrey it was my gal and it was
such a low thing to do I should have
just firmed it taking the consequences
and that would have been that but I was
a cowardly child and I'm sorry for oh
I'm so amazing but now I know what the
timing how you were so angry at me I
threw you so far because I didn't I
think I didn't realize you were throwing
because I don't think you didn't tell me
straight away because I think I I think
it was something on along the lines of I
must have come to see you and obviously
at the time you were still with the god
something like that and I and I wanted
to well I think I opted to come and see
you said no or something because obvious
I wanted to come and show you man and
you're like nothing's good ideal
something like that I remember that so
basically obviously I've thrown you
under the bus and all that stuff mmm but
because me thrown you under the bus
didn't absolve me of anything yeah yeah
yeah I still had to deal with this [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah he just kind of deflected
it slightly so because it didn't absolve
me of anything I'd almost forgotten that
I even threw you under the bus because I
still had to deal with it it didn't get
me out of anywhere it just kind of just
put a pause so I could catch my thoughts
and then attack again yeah that's all it
did it was a quick spanner in the works
so I could come to my senses and think
okay this is the game plan for now mmm
so obviously I'd done that and she
didn't even bring your name up in
regards to it again until something like
you wanting to calm down and she said
something like he ain't staying here or
something like that and I was like the
[ __ ] you told me and obviously this is
way after that so all that's done and
died off and she I was like are sick
three hundred come and visit or whatever
for it well and I think it's for a
couple of days and she was like where he
ain't coming this is it mmm
this is it this is it no we weren't
together okay me and her weren't
together mmm me and her weren't together
but we still shared a house we still
share the house
hmm so I said to her you're gonna be
coming up for a few days and she said he
ain't staying in this house and it
wasn't me in her heart to give her
anyway so you can stay in whatever house
I [ __ ] deem you can stay in and
you're my best friend and obviously I'm
not me in her but together stuff of that
but like she's not a spiteful person for
the sake of being spiteful she can be
but whatever she's a good person and I
remember her saying he ain't coming in
this house and I was so flabbergasted
and I think she wasn't even gonna be
there but I think I think she was gonna
go somewhere anyway so I remember I
remember thinking you're not even gonna
be here so how can you tell me that my
best friend is not coming to stay in my
[ __ ] house yeah but what are you even
talking about
and she was like he's the most
disrespectful but he don't respect me as
a person he's not coming in my house and
I was like what on the bow I've known
him longer than I've known you yeah you
guys love each other anyway
like what are you talking about and she
was like are you stupid
he told he came up with this [ __ ]
name for this [ __ ] girl when we were
in a relationship and stuff like that he
had no respect for me whatsoever and
then he remembered that I told her that
I thought was like oh no oh no oh no she
actually remembers oh she has he
remembers and now even though we were
together obviously lived in the same
house and so for that I couldn't just
come out and be like oh so no he didn't
I just said that mm to save my own skin
because then I'm at the house I still
need a roof yeah
and Amina still needs to be civil yeah
so yeah and then that happened and I was
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] so then I remember
having to come to you and be like bro
we're gonna have to stay at my mom's cuz
it's not a good idea for you to stay
here and you and then I can't remember
if I had to tell you no that's when I
told you out throwing you under the bus
yeah that's when I told you were
throwing you under the bus and I I was
riddled with guilt riddled with it
because she didn't deserve that
yeah she didn't deserve to not like you
as a person for something you'd not done
yeah and you didn't deserve to deal with
the consequences of something you'd not
done I was the cause of all of it and it
was just so bad it's one of the worst
times of my life
I'm riddled with guilt and I still
wasn't man enough to come clean and just
say it was me yeah the whole thing was
me I'm a bad guy let's just move on yeah
what a horrible time to think about what
a horrible time to think about [ __ ]
now brother that was bad that was a
lifetime ago though he was so long ago
but that was bad
Jesus oh my god a story indeed we have
so we have exactly the same story but
such different perspectives on it that's
crazy it is it's so crazy exactly the
same story just different perspective
there's mad it's so mad do you also
realize this is so like on unrelated do
you not realize how obviously we're
getting old now we're 29 oh yeah
what did you ever did you ever realize
the point where you're getting too old
to go to an after-party I can't remember
the last time I went to an after-party
afterparty in terms in terms of you're
going out you're ready for a night out
yes go out yes and then after the show
summers people I said oh let's go back
to mine let's go back to mine and
continue this that's so that's such an
interesting point that you've made
because no I don't remember a time where
one day yes I was up for it and the next
I wasn't but you couldn't pay me to do
that now Sam you can pay me to do
there's been stories you've told me in
the last couple of years where you told
me this happened this happened and I've
thought you're probably fortunate that I
was in there mmm god I'm not dealing
with any other yeah oh especially when
it comes to like things that you do for
[ __ ] mmm like in the lot is probably
somewhere in the like it's quite a long
time is probably
in the last five years or so hmm but
there's been spaces in the last four or
five years where there's things that I
would have done for [ __ ] at the time
that you could not pay me good good
money to do do do now yeah
if the sun's coming up It's A Wrap yeah
I promise you it's around I'm not doing
[ __ ] yeah so no one can invite me after
the trips is done the ships is done I
want food in my belly and I want a warm
bed yeah he's crazy
I don't remember the day that I was like
I'm not doing this anymore leave it a
while but I remember times I think I say
this there was a time in my life where I
would have stayed up to whatever time so
to keep the party going I remember I
used to be the guy that was way up for
early hours right like anything to keep
the party rolling I was down yeah and I
remember the threesome story the nearly
threesome story you're one yeah yes yes
it was like a perfect example yeah of a
time in my life where one I would have
gone through wherever trials to get
[ __ ] and for two as long as the fun
continues I don't care I just don't want
it to end I'll fight through any level
of tiredness yeah like I remember soul I
have I ever taught three story I don't
know but I know it like the back of an
exactly I don't think I've taught on
here but basically there was a time
right where I'm pretty sure the decline
must have started happen in a couple
years after this event because in this
event it resonates in my head or the way
I remember this event is just like the
last straw do you know I'm saying yeah
and you look at yourself in the mirror
you're black enough is enough
mmm like yeah I was I didn't even feel
too old for him it's just like enough is
enough
like we're basically me and my friend
were a night out we'd met two girls and
they'd said to us do we want to go to
another club that closes at 6:00 this
must've been about three or four and
said this comes close and you wanna come
with us to another club closes at 6:00
obviously I'm like hell yeah hell yeah
so we go with them to this next up and
we end up staying there all the way till
6:00 so
6.now and the sun's already glistening
hmm then they're like Juwanna guys want
to come back to ours for some more
drinks I'm still like heaviest my boys
like [ __ ] this but he rolls with me so
we got in the sacks we get back to this
and then me and wanting upstairs a Twix
game yeah we came busy in a good way
we're busy busy
yeah and I'm gang mmm so this is this is
such a horrible story it's not horrible
story but it's just like don't people
doing drunk [ __ ] that sounds cool at the
time but no you look back is are these
least cool [ __ ] so obviously as a man I
wanted nothing more in my life than a
threesome mmm and we've had that
conversation before like it's just a
tick off that you just want to get
ticked off yeah and you don't even know
if the experience is gonna be good
you just need to tick it off it's just
something that you've done it just to
say you've done it and lived that so
we're there my boy basically falls
asleep on their couch downstairs and
then the one that he was talking to was
just bored out of her mind now so my
thing that I'm dealing with we didn't
[ __ ] were anything like that but we got
like very close she for some reason goes
downstairs and tells her friend I don't
know how the conversation goes but the
friend comes upstairs without the one
that I was dealing with she comes up
myself and cut me exactly how she
phrased it but was basted he said my
friend says you got a big dick and I'm
like okay and she was like I want to see
sober James would have been like no no I
have dignity yeah I'm not just gonna
pull out like I did yeah I'm just not
going to pull out my dick yeah and drunk
James was like hell yeah
weeps out she was like gang she started
throwing the word throwing around she
was out well your friends asleep and in
so many ways she was basically saying
I'm jumping in with you two then hmm
so I'm not gonna go to the gory details
but we got very close and in my head I'm
like threesomes [ __ ] happening I so
hmm I could not [ __ ] this up so with the
threesome is about to be secured yeah
we're basically doing it now yeah
come now there's just this just get
right down to it so I can take off this
off nothing else can go wrong nothing
else can go wrong and I will do anything
to make sure it goes right mmm so so
what happened was is that one of the
things the one thing that I was
originally dealing with just caught
myself a conscience I was like now I
don't really want to do this like I've
only just broken up my boyfriend and I
feel like I'm only here because out of
like a revenge not a revenge thing but
just like a rebound thing
and now we're getting mixed up in all
this [ __ ] and it's not really me so I'm
just I think I'm out
I heard bridging the the other one was
like I mean mmm and I was like fair
enough consolation prize let's just go
with the one-on-one so now I've lost the
threesome but I'm still going for the
one mmm especially since she's the one
that says you want to do the free some
of the first things I'm thinking that's
the other one yeah not they're not
thinking then that's gonna be good mmm
so we're getting down to it and I
thinking I don't want to lose this but
I'm thinking this is a sure thing and
then burn my now it's like seven half
eight seven eight o'clock in the morning
and [ __ ] hell she at nowhere she
clear-- party girl she out of nowhere is
like I really want to do some cocaine
and I was like swear I've never done
cocaine in my life she's I really want
to do some cocaine like I want to do
coke and then [ __ ] like crazy and then
I'm like okay mmm do what you need to do
like I'm not doing it with you but go do
you take it she's like I haven't got any
like can you get me some and I'm like no
I can't get you some so I run downstairs
get my phone and I know what guy who
knows okay some way end up picking up my
phone when my drunk ass call him my boy
I'm being like bro riveting she needs
some cocaine and I'm looking outside as
I'm on the phone and it's light outside
and I'm ringing my friend secure cocaine
for some random [ __ ] I don't even know
in a random house and I'm just like with
my
to sleep on the sofa and I'm like what
the [ __ ] am i doing yeah what I might do
it like I'm getting mixed up in all
sorts for [ __ ] and fun like what what
is happening like James what are you
doing brother so I literally just locked
off because he was sleeping [ __ ] yeah
I've woke him up and I was like here
gonna do this for me anyway and I
embarrassed to even ask him because he
knows me and he knows I don't do drugs
so the fact that I'm asking him to do me
a favor and secure some drugs for a
random go at [ __ ] o'clock in the
morning it's just sad sad so before I
even asked him I just saw bro actually
forget it I'm sorry and she was out
what's going on and I was like babes
we've got a guy so welcome my boy got a
taxi left and I was so drunk that once
the taxi dropped me off I had my head in
an alley
vomiting really I was vomiting before I
got in my house and I once I finished
pharmacy and I was just like cuz I'm
seeing people walking their dogs and
[ __ ] early morning now when I'm coming
home from a night owl just puking in the
streets and I was just like bro my
life's a [ __ ] joke that time that's
the last time I even though that was so
many years ago here
and I was a lot younger that's one of
the first time so I remember thinking
this I fell for me this after pike [ __ ]
ain't for me I have so much fun in the
club but I'm ruining it yeah from what
oft happens after us because now the
whole night is a bust for me yeah all I
can think is that I had a great time
almost had a threesome and everything
after that was god-awful mmm so yeah
that's I don't remember the day that I
was like I'm not doing after pies
anymore but now if you ask me to go
after ye never in a million years bro
you already know me as soon I'm tired
before we go out you are
I'm tired before we get you excited to
go out to go out in the first place it's
such a hassle such a house I'm so tired
all the time
and I don't know why hmm I don't know I
just am my body duck can't operate like
it used to
it just can't I used a higher bro we
used to party we used to buy that crazy
party I couldn't do that now I'm
done when it's two o'clock I'm done
saying I'm done mmm so that's why I come
in like obviously white back then white
rain even now why it rains and black
races are so different because if it's a
white rave and it starts at 10:00 man
damn I'd never attend half 9:00 from
there Cuban there dare at 10:00 no
wonder they're tight cuz they're
different tensile three yeah five hours
right I can't pay for that long
nope know if I'm going now I'm if I'm
there at midnight that says that's a
stretch I'm usually there like before
just before 1:00 and I'm there till to
close so that's a good three hours if
that and I'm still tired after that for
all these times I I'm content
leaving if you hit me up if we were in a
club mmm and you hit me up at 1:30 and
this is peak now this is the best it's
nice yeah yeah you hear me upper 130 is
they probably wanna grab some food now
that I've seen it at its peak I'm more
than content to be like gang mmm let's
bounce
I'm having a good time the fam I'm tired
I'm so [ __ ] tired and there was a
time in my life where we went out I
remembers me you and Kier came up mmm
and we had the best night one time in
hush yeah and we went out early yeah
some reason we ran out early and it was
a non-stop Pyatt I felt like I've been
there for six hours I was getting tired
and I looked at the time and it was like
11 58 and I remember thinking this the
best thing ever like I feel like I've
been here all day yeah and it's still
just early early I can go forever if
that happened now it would be for the
complete opposite reasons I would look
at the time think broth I've been here
four time I'm ready to go and I look at
11:58 and I'll be too embarrassed to say
Jim I'm tired I wanna go
it's lady midnight yeah yeah I'm tired I
wanna go I know exactly what you mean we
old [ __ ]
well you're old [ __ ] farts bro I
can't party like it you see I miss it
don't get me wrong but with in the same
breath and thinking we just had to go
through that everyone has to go through
that to evolve it's true everyone has to
go through that kinda stuff right and I
love the fact they did it mm-hmm but now
I'm just so it just doesn't matter to me
it's the way thing as well was that like
you don't it doesn't bother you because
you genuinely don't want to be there you
know I'm saying it's not like you're
tired but you wish you weren't tired so
you can carry on yeah is this like bro I
just don't even want to be here anymore
I'd rather be in bed hmm and that's so
lame is as much as I love the music as
much as I love the viable I I could kill
for some food and the kid where I make
hot McDonald's
I bet big man you nuts
yeah perfect combination sign me the
[ __ ] for comments I me the [ __ ] up hot
fresh mint Donald's and [ __ ] hot hips
hold all those chips so I sit on ratio
ah I could scream after shake every MUC
done as a please I'm dead in there bro
the best thing for some fresh barbeque
sauce the sweet ting yes I love
McDonald's I miss it I miss men miss it
bro it's not [ __ ] it's not I bro that is
the perfect now to me perfect and now
we'll wake up the next day hopefully no
hangover because my hangovers are
[ __ ] dreadful oh I know they are
grateful I know they are I don't know I
don't know a single person who suffers
the way I suffer in a hangover because
we always have to drive somewhere off
the woods driving for a decade
afterwards I'm a driving for 12 years
Basia mad bro yeah it's [ __ ] long
cause and I owe ya no matter what I've
always got drives on with us because
I'll even the [ __ ] sticks and no one
ever comes to pie where I am I've always
got to drive somewhere hmm and the drive
home is so long yes I've got Drive from
today
oh no as soon as we turn off this camera
I've got a three-hour drive home and I'm
tired for you had I know you are I hope
we had a couple drinks last night we had
a couple of drinks last night we didn't
go anywhere we had a couple drinks I
said I'm tired I don't want to go I'm
sorry gee I want to sleep I know you
because I want to sleep three hours in
the car I can't wait for this to be over
cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna light the [ __ ]
down switch on my fan and now oh I'm
jealous cuz it's one of them ones I'm
jealous
the monsters not slapping the way it
used to it is but it's not hitting like
it's not it's not gonna get me through
the drive hmm I'm gonna stop on the
drive and take a deep breath
show me I'm gonna pull in one so like
I'm gonna put into a service station and
just be like you just got a question it
all I'm gonna check my side amaz like 2
hours and 15 minutes left
[ __ ] you gotta shoot yourself yeah you
got the steering room and you shake the
guy so man invent teleportation oh I'll
pay whatever they want
oh I'll pay whatever they what Ivan will
be obsolete I can't wait for that but I
love my cars I love cars but drive and
be done
teleportation that's the next thing
that's the next thing
what's traffic that's the next thing
brav or even [ __ ] self-driving cars
so I can get in the whip and put the
seat back they hit scare the living
Christ I love me cuz it only takes one
thing to go wrong the Ute oh yeah oh
yeah and I can't I can't trust machine
that much at the at the sake of my life
it's crazy do you know what's actually
crazy because obviously Tesla do that
now yeah so it's crazy that I think like
a seriously high percentage like even
though they're so not advanced enough to
take over the vast majority of the
crashes they've had have been caused by
the people in the other cars not the
actual water driving car hmm the machine
is fine the machines doing is always
supposed to do but the time it's crashed
he's to do with the other [ __ ] cars
oh and the and obviously but he just
gets ticked off as a crash it's a
failure it doesn't know how to deal with
people doing that's the thing the car
doesn't know how the machine doesn't
know how to react to [ __ ] drivers so
with all the cars and machines
ain't no one crashing but the machine
doesn't know how to deal with people
doing dumb [ __ ]
you can only react to weights yeah
weights not supposed to do it only knows
when this person is entering this Lane I
pull back at this one or I speed up for
this one or I stay in these lines and I
need to keep this much distance between
the car in front of me stuff like that
but when some random ER is just bombing
it past than cutting in lanes it doesn't
what to do
so slams on the brakes cuz didn't
doesn't know what if I can do and in the
car behind it smashes into it and you
know are these these auto driver cost at
work crazy interesting five years range
I don't know if I could I'd have to if
I'd do it I'd have to do is unlike your
film in the past if I'm driving someone
else has to be in a passenger seat with
me what if I let go just in case yeah I
mean and I wouldn't sleep I would just
test it I'll just test it there's people
that fallenness sleep I know there's
videos over people I keep in a scary on
the cars doing the whole thing that's
scary
all terrifying if I woke up oh my god
and I'm in a different place how
terrified would you be bro there's times
if you have fallen asleep at the wheel
before not completely but I've like
nodded off like mmm like you normally do
like you just oh [ __ ] but then I wind
under window play music it loud cuz I've
driven home drunk so many times like
this is so bad
I've driven home drunk so many times but
it's nothing worse than driving home
tired
there's nothing from Warsong in this
world you can't do because asleep do not
mean hmm when you'll snoot when you're
dozing you can't stop like you've been
there and you you're there and obviously
you under my way so you can't even pull
over somewhere and you're doing it and
you're like for the love of God stop
those are not and you just can't you
just can't you race home you race home
windows open water on my face music
blasting music blasting making bro it's
a scariest feeling the scariest feeling
driver home tired it's the worst oh it's
terrible it's terrible I fear so much
but when you doze and the car swerves
and then you wake up that time you're
awake your body can't go through that
again bro
your heart can't take it your weight
come afterwards of me before us
adrenaline that's probably a shot of
adrenaline
yeah 100% that happens
before that was the time I told you to
someone had swine flu in it years ago
when I was like 18
you've probably told me but that's a
distant memory I don't know these
mapping Co vids bad hmm
swine flu was a next thing worst illness
I've ever had really worse than the time
when I thought I had said I had a Corona
mmm worse than that time when I caught
swine flu oh my god I thought you'd died
I was in my room non-stop for two weeks
that's how I was when I caught malaria
but continued mmm but yeah anyway I
caught swine flu in basketball camp and
it was like a three and a half hour
drive home and I was getting someone I
was getting ill so I wasn't in the peak
of illness whiny today bedridden this is
where I'm starting to realize I'm really
[ __ ] ill yeah like the day before him
I've had a sore throat for a bit
sluggish this day I'm thinking oh I'm
getting ill yeah ill ill it's gonna be a
bad one and I'm driving home from I
can't stay awake and all my boys are in
the car and they're all asleep and I'm
like I can't stay awake worse but you
can't sport drivers that's the world
none of them had a license as well no
one I was the only driver and I was
dozing fam and then literally dozed one
time and it swerved into the now was
this close to hitting the car next to me
this close bro whoa cups worth back in
and my boy behind me woke up I said what
the [ __ ] was that and I was like nine
fam he looked at me like I know what was
yeah I know what it will stay the [ __ ]
away was he behind you yeah that's the
funniest vision in my head right now
because you both know what happened
you're trying your hardest to convince
him nothing happened bro fear in your
eyes I was looking in the rearview watch
giveaway and that was like nothing no I
know what the [ __ ] happened my life
don't risk my life for your tiredness
these times these my claw drive bro no
work is right they usually me that's
what they used me and I'm ill I was the
swine got the [ __ ] swine I don't know
how I made at home thought I've ever
told you that summer got malaria mm-hmm
it was in Nigeria this was probably when
I was in year eight cuz I had been to
Nigeria price that I like to and fro for
honey when I school there that's when I
caught at that point I was staying at my
aunties house
remember when I was feet started to feel
sick obviously I did in a way was I was
being drained yeah wouldn't hold
anything in I was losing weight like
obviously I'm big enough I was losing
weight back then mm I was thinking [ __ ]
him
ill hmm what sealed it for me was this
was the first time is that I've had to
be I went to the toilet because I wanted
to throw up I'm speaking oh my god I'm
gonna throw up and I don't know what
like you know when it's it comes out of
nowhere and you get swayed like that
family it comes out of nowhere from it
um not terrifying
oh my god I need to [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh God
so you know when you ever have you ever
been in that situation where you need to
throw up and share the same time not not
to the not to the point where I need to
[ __ ] now I've never been in a situation
so bro luckily the toilet I went in the
the sink was so close to the toilet
mm-hmm it saved my life kind of thing
that you could vomit in the sink and
[ __ ] the same time so bear in mind I was
vomiting first yeah see and you know me
when I vomit well yeah yeah you do shake
a sweat thing everything everything it's
an ordeal for me you know I mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah so as soon as as soon as
I felt like I needed a [ __ ] I thought my
world is gonna end because I don't know
how to maneuver now hmm because it's
coming out blue fence
yes what turn round I start in and I'm
thinking because you know when you think
you finished for me yes that moment of
hope yeah I can breathe yes I'm [ __ ]
now yeah and I'm thinking please God
don't let me so you're pushing but you
think it doesn't want me to push it
wants to come up yeah I'm thinking oh my
lord oh my lord if so why I want someone
to kill me I lean over because the the
sink is just on the right just that yeah
yeah for me and for me van I've never
been so scared in my entire life I
promise you know I'd beg someone to
murder me son put me out my misery
straightaway
I don't know what's going on but I'm not
okay I'm not okay
they told me the hostels that night I
stayed for days they said I've got
malaria oh my god
what's the first thing I can only get
once wait you get I think you can only
get it once or couple times in your life
mmm but because my body wasn't he was
used to getting bitten by mosquitoes
when I used to go there on holiday mmm
but because I was living there my blood
was fresh today yeah so they were raping
they raped me
I've got mosquito bites foot bro bro bro
area is not the one that doesn't sound
good
I was scared in the hospital that's the
first time I'd ever been to hospital
land or anything not a drip and all sort
it's the first time have I ever told you
I've told you to survive ever told the
story about when I lost the testicle
when I almost lost a testicle on here
you haven't are down here we haven't
spoke about in years go for it so this
this then so that malaria was the first
time I'd ever been to school for
anything the second time I've been
Hospital was when I broke my wrist I
probably spoke about on mmm the third
time a new boy went Hospital wasn't in
it when I nearly locking heart speak
when I nearly [ __ ] lost a testicle
and I'll tell you what happened I was I
was at home this is back in England I
was I'm at Mom's house was me my mom my
sister at home I was asleep and I woke
up with the craziest pain in my balls
and I hadn't done anything the night
before he was a pain it wasn't her and
the night before it wasn't her in during
the night it was hurting as soon as I
woke up panting God maybe I just need to
piss like maybe maybe I've been holding
it on and I didn't realize but it was
just one test of it wasn't to I'm
thinking oh my god why I mean why I mean
I am I said there's no comparison to the
pain I felt I've never felt this kind of
pain in my entire life and I promise you
you don't want to feel that pain I
promise you I promise you I come home
hurt I promise you it was painful
yes I'm now I'm a I'm a I'm a timeout
crossroads do i firm it or do i have the
balls to tell a pun intended
do I have the balls to tell my mom that
my balls are hurting me no I wasn't have
that converse
I'm not having a conversation that
conversation haha bro yeah let load
themselves yeah I'm fighting it like
[ __ ] what do I do
hmm I never truly tell my mum and then
she's like okay let's go to let's go to
the local GP down the road so we go to
that low could you've been on the road
I'm in there for like probably up 20
minutes I've told him a situation
they're like 19 it's go to A&E that's
not saying we can deal with I'm like oh
my god oh my god so mom's driving now my
balls are in agony yeah my balls were in
agony yeah so I have to I can't
obviously when you walk your balls are
closed your clothes yeah yeah walk in
like a penguin yeah yeah bowlegged I
can't risk my ball hitting my life oh
because that's the sort of pain I was in
so when I sat down in the car my legs
were open I think my legs were on the
windshield because my legs I thought
like I was I thought when I was giving
birth do you know I mean yeah if I get
to A&E now and they I tell them the
whole shebang like yeah yeah we can sort
it I'm like thank the Lord but the
doctors that's meant to sort it isn't
another hospital doing another surgery
on former wardens an end yes world was
going to end I was like when is this
gonna subside so they're off now yeah
butch Ronnie I'm chilling now I'm
chilling just waiting Oh finally comes
he takes like an hour safe but that
hours probably the worst out Laramie
yeah yeah finally comes I have to not
tell him again the story and he tells me
it's it's a torch is a contortion of the
testicle they are some tapenade that you
think that in your sleep you're you're
one of your testicles can twist and not
twist back in the sack so it twisted
wasn't getting any more oxygen oh my god
so it stopped the flow of blood and
everything oh my god he said if I hadn't
come when I had come or if he wasn't
there when that if I probably waited
about three more hours my testicle would
have been blue and I would have lost it
literal blue ball I literally would have
had a blue ball and I would have lost it
obviously while he's telling me this
he's still not 100% sure that the
surgery is gonna sort sort it you know
it means I'm [ __ ] terrified there's a
possible
see I can still lose a testicle yeah I'm
thinking tape meat it off to the ward
now do what you need to do now are we
talking it the more time we're talking
the water I am bluer and bluer bluer and
bluer I'm getting so Damien let's go Wow
let's don't need my husband
let's go yeah but the same time I'm
thinking that the same time I am so
petrified of waking up with one testicle
mm-hmm do you not I mean yeah not cool
so he done the surgery I mean I don't
remember falling asleep nothing thing I
remember getting on the table robot by
don't even that's how quick that thing
works I've never had it I'm so intrigued
by it
so am i because when I see on TV I'm
diggin not a speck but I remember it's
happened to me by I don't remember
falling asleep Wow one Wow then man had
my balls open logically did what he had
to do and I woke up on a bed and that
was it and the pain was gone they could
have done anything to me they could have
done anything to me I just woke up one
day I just woke up and I remember
thinking if anything I remember thinking
before I wake up I just thought to
myself I pray I wake up and have two
balls yeah yeah so the first thing I
thought was was [ __ ] I'm awake now okay
let me find any one person I asked I
knew the person really it was so weird
the person I asked I think she was doing
an internship at the hospital or she was
doing like what something I thought she
was like an intern year hmm I knew her
through mosque cuz mummy my family's
good too when I say ma'am I thought my
parents still go when I used to go
mosque with my family there was a chick
they always used to go as well actually
I think she's like a family friend or
some stuff always you see ya can't remem
never liked em about always you see ya
so when I saw her a swing kid one okay
thank what I seen for meaning Facebook
to [ __ ] half the Oscar now do I have do
I have two testicles hmm so it's all
good again [ __ ] so when I asked her she
was like yeah well brow brows I thank
God but the recovery process of that had
to where it was essentially a diaper
that's where essentially a diaper for
six weeks the six week where you keep
this [ __ ] boom
you keep it so for for yourself weeks
it's embarrassing cause bet firm
I remember you'd only told me after
you'd whoa
mmm you didn't mention the whole thing
to any of us I remember cuz I said in
the group remember yeah I was like what
yeah like I think you said something
like you man
I need lost the pool today or something
like that and then you told the whole
sequence of events and it's like am I
just a Chatty Cathy can I just not
keepin it into myself because whilst
that happened I'll be messaging you that
hey you man I'm terrified
someone consoled me who's I'm scared of
here's what's going down
I didn't I think I just couldn't process
earlier to be fair I was now that you
mentioned how much pain you were in
I wouldn't even looked on my phone
there's no what I don't give a [ __ ]
about my for yeah that was in was
unbearable [ __ ] unbearable worst I've
ever had in my entire life and I've
broken I've broken my wrist before yeah
that's the work my ballsack twisting oh
wow pain I've ever had in my entire life
that's all for my entire life and I want
to wish time always enemy [ __ ] [ __ ]
roar that's a good end listen wrap it up
our girls grow up thanks again guys see
you next week